[Music]
Stephanie Holman is back Real Housewives
of Dallas is back season three yes I'm
excited this is probably my first year
where I'm not extremely nervous
it was nice investing in drama it's not
in my budget how is this year different
than the first two seasons oh my
goodness is the first year I feel like
I'm friends with every single one the
one of the women which is nice and I
used to go in to group events and like
feel like I was having like a mini panic
attack and the shariah actually was
enjoying everybody we see in the trailer
you say - Leeanne I do feel like you've
changed maybe other people don't I do
has she really changed I will say this
year I saw a side of land that I've
never seen before she really really
tried with me and I appreciate that at
an event and her through we ended up
sitting by each other and we had a
really good conversation about things we
both struggle with and we both have
struggled in the past with depression
this made me look at her very
differently like I saw a piece of myself
in her and maybe she saw a piece of
herself in me Leeanne love her or hate
her I really do feel like she really
really worked on herself this year and
did she have setbacks yes but I do feel
like the core of who she has is somebody
who wants to change
let go of all other thoughts she can
bang on a bowl a few months but she's
toxic
now brandy and Leanne are not in a good
place
no that's hard the one thing I can say
for brandy and I appreciate is that she
never once made me feel like I have to
choose which is nice not everyone does
that
last year the viewers really love some
of the darker moments
nice
Tommy be real careful I'm gonna kill her
you're gonna kill Marie and you're gonna
slit my throat if I go behind your back
so [ __ ] you and good luck with your
wedding is there anything at that level
this season there are times whenever I
was standing in a room with the women
and I left not believing what I just
witnessed yeah definitely you'll have to
wait and see but there are times
whenever I was even shocked yes is that
early in the season late in the season
all season I would say moments all
season long but definitely late in the
season like mid to late season you're
like holy cow
pick a drink to that yes have you had to
sum up this season with just one word
what would your words be and why I feel
like it's intense because there are
issues that happen with them and that
you don't expect and they're raw and
they're real people that are really good
friends are fighting and it's different
how relationships change
well congrats on surviving the third
season always good so good to see you
[Music]